So let's think of a good parallel algorithm to solve this problem.
So here's some of the characteristics that we want out of our algorithm.
We want lots of parallelism, coalesced memory access, minimal execution divergence,
and something that's easy to implement.
And I want to show you an algorithm that gives you all of those characteristics,
and then I'm going to tell you why it's a crummy algorithm.
So as we're going along, I want you to think about why this algorithm isn't going to be good enough.
So here's what we're going to do.
First I'm going to describe the algorithm at a high level,
then we're going to do an example, then we're going look at code.
So at a high level, we're going to operate over our list of edges.
Then we're going to iterate n times, where n is the maximum depth of the graph.
So on each iteration, n parallel,
we can look at each edge independently in n parallel.
And if one end of that edge has a depth d
but we haven't visited the other end of the edge yet, the vertex on the other side,
then we set that vertex to depth d plus 1.
So the first iteration will set all the vertices that have depth 1.
The next iteration will set all the vertices with depth 2 and so on.
So let's do an example.